what was your first experience of the
Internet
first experience of the internet doing
me any good actually didn't come
properly you know until 1984 with email
and you're talking 1969 so in the
meantime it was that it was just for a
small select few I think I've had the
internet since I was a baby because my
dad was always into it we started with a
56k modem and so that took a long time
to connect a lot of beeps I used to be
able to hum it back exactly I don't
think I did I could do it now no no
maybe you didn't know it was 15 years
before I saw any benefit from that
so-called breakthrough yeah what was
that benefit just it was email so the
first thing I remember it was in 1984
when I was a PhD student at the
University of Sheffield and we were
connected to the Janet net for the first
time and we got access to email so a
group of five or six of us gathered
around the terminal and sent an email to
Edinburgh to Andrew blank who was
recently the director of the turing
institute and we sent him an email that
said hello Andrew we then waited three
days for it to arrive and we had to keep
bringing him up to find out when it had
got there but he did get there I
remember using old computers that were
next to no I definitely primary school
they were like BBC computers and we were
doing some nomad game and that was
networked at least whether it was online
I'm not sure I think mostly it was of
web access and I was boarding websites
fairly young at 15 it was fun to do but
yeah just slow loading noisy Internet's
as what I knew one of my first memories
I guess is sitting in an internet cafe
in Cambridge a number of years ago with
a one of the first web browsers so
was it I want to say like Netscape or
something like this and opening up the
web browser and actually seeing web
pages for like the first time really
that was probably my one of my first
memories I this must have been 25 years
ago so you know not a long time ago man
yeah yeah a while ago so I was in a
University of Technical University of
Berlin and we had yeah we had the first
connection to up on that or whatever it
was at that time and so what I was doing
yes I I was I was subscribed to the to
the Anarchy mailing list which was
pretty pretty interesting so my dad
worked at BT during the 90s so he was
involved with like really helping rollin
turn out so it was quite cutting edge in
our house and I remember we had dial-up
and having to hang up the phone every
time we wanted to use the internet I
used to drive my mum's back because
she'd want us to get off in case
somebody called well one of the first
times I went online I started reading
frac which is a an ascii only digital
magic magazine about how to hack
telephones in particular and and how to
get free onto the onto the internet
system and yeah I just thought it was
fantastic so for me I think it was good
around my friend Alan's house and going
on bulletin board systems to arrange
games of doom too so that was probably
what the early 90s 94 and 85 son like
that
and then coming home and learning about
apples
ye world which was a whole new world for
us really excited to thought it's gonna
be gooeys now isn't it you're gonna have
like a picture of your time and you go
to your a little email area and it was
not like that it was really bad this
whole community of people who are trying
to understand this system that was still
being developed and it was sort of like
a an active race of people trying to
figure out how it works and how you can
subvert it it was forever because the
telcos
did interests got in the way they wanted
to run the world and I had to be told
firmly that it wasn't just them so yes
of course if you were to ask me how if
it took that long to get to email how
long did it take from the nineteen sixty
nine to get to the World Wide Web and
browsers everywhere
well none 1994 it took 25 years for it
to get beneficial enough that people
could casually visit for the sites and
see web pages and stuff quite amazing I
don't actually remember the first time I
got on the Internet
it probably would have been at school I
would think we did eventually get
America online but I think I would have
seen it first at school I sort of
remember search edges coming out open
but you know the early days of searching
for things and sort of being excited by
that and also curious that you know I
remember contributing to is it open
directory something like that I remember
like that about being like an
independent hockey director equivalent I
remember sort of adding sites to bat in
sort of your playing my part in like a
young child contributing to what I felt
was gonna be the future how people find
things yeah I was pretty long time ago
when I was using one of those Oh more
than 28 kilobytes that took like two
minutes to connect and then my father
was saying what the hell is that no I
said you have why don't you take the
phone I think it was like back in Spain
something called terror about acid then
collapsed at some point I was pretty fun
actually but that's the only search
engine that we had at the time and you
couldn't do much with it to be honest
yeah but that's good
quite fun at the time we got an amazing
three kilobytes per second download you
know so that was maybe a you know if you
were downloading an mp3 that would be
you know quite a while it would take as
opposed to fractions of a second you had
the the phone cable that I was dragging
through the whole house and you'd have
to ask the parents cause it wasn't like
oh they were still I'm from Luxembourg
so we still had a different currency and
it cost like you know five francs per
minute to use the internet and
I couldn't call yes the good old days I
do remember that as soon as I understood
what the internet was and how it worked
I immediately started trying to make my
own website which I did was terrible but
that's my my my early memories of the
Internet are like trying to write HTML
in all caps in notepad was a simpler
time I was thinking last night about
bulletin boards and the fact that
actually with social media we're just
going back to doing exactly the same
things now it's great you know we're
just posting stuff for people to see
it's the same stuff the first stuff I
remember I suppose is listening to a
modem dial-up to connect to web pages
nor there were that many web pages then
but the ones that did exist seem to be
absolutely loaded with blinking flashing
banners saying under construction and
garish cyan fonts as a nightmare first
memory of using internet was in 1994 my
brother just got back from the
University and found out about the
internet and so when we had to have it
at home and so we bought a 28 u.s.
robotics modem for our acorn archimedes
a three thousand which was the family
computer and you couldn't do much web
browsing at the time because the a 3000
wasn't much good at it so I spent a lot
of time on telnet chat rooms so they
were called talkers at the time it was a
bit like a BBS you could log on and talk
to people on in kind of a terminal
interface so I spent hours on that and
then it all came crashing down when
after a month of having that we got the
phone bill which was for about 150
pounds basically all of me
all for my dine up internet talking and
from then on I was limited to half an
hour a day on internet when I started
using the internet I was doing my
masters studies so and it was but in my
country of alien origin in Mexico in a
city called Chihuahua like the dog fell
pretty exciting you know I guess that's
probably one of the reasons I went into
computer science is you kind of saw this
massive opportunity of you know there's
suddenly all this stuff's available and
there's things we
can do with it and yeah let's try and
avoid some of the more visually
unappealing fonts but there's things we
can do with the internet right I've
never got any better at lab by the way
websites were a lot simpler back then so
I remember the start of Google it looked
kind of the same but you know different
font and stuff it was obviously not
quite the juggernaut it is now and and
then just fun websites like hamster
dance comm I don't know if you remember
this it's so animated gifts were a big
thing back in the late 90s
I mean gifts are coming back a bit
actually but I just want to say that you
know we started this you know we aren't
my generation started the animated gif
in a big way so hamster on SOCOM I went
on the wayback machine the Internet
Archive and found it
this is hamster dance calm it had fun
music yeah it had lots of animated
hamster gifts it serves no purpose at
all and that's still what the intents
for us she's having very little purpose
but you know back then they took it to a
to a different level
so yeah hamster dance calm and other
animated gif related nonsense well this
I'm looking here at 2000 but I would say
999 2000 some for somewhere around that
we didn't start I mean Facebook didn't
exist until 2004 so this is before that
websites were if you look down websites
with mostly text hit counters at the
bottom of websites were a big deal right
we you know people wanted you to know
what a thousand people have been to
their website exact it's just like that
just like that she looks was all just
you stood manager and that message was
about years that I had a motorbike
accident in 1980 something 81 or
something and the first big
embarrassment I had for company I
developed a father generator and common
lisp and then somebody asked interested
in the code and I was going to send it
to him and then I sent it to the mailing
list and and I wasn't supposed to do
this and then he told me oh this your
code is now already in Texas and the
company first so I think the first time
I really remember going online was
probably at primary school and we used
to have some math lessons in the
computer room where we get to play math
games very educational
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I remember asking my dad like multiple
times how do I spell Google I can never
remember and they were before Google I
remember sort of typing in how to
program calm and other things calm in
the hope that it would find the you know
something interesting with but actually
websites loaded nice and quickly even on
the 56k modem because it's really only
about five images instant text on here
so you know maybe it wasn't so bad I
think all my friends at Primary School
had email addresses by the final year
and we'd be emailing each other after
school I lived in a house with 11 guys
learning students and for quite a long
time and I built our own server that
allowed everybody to you know use the
internet through it and actually we
first used
coaxial cable was an end-to-end cable
and but then at some point we moved to
Ethernet but I was amazed how at that
time all passwords were just sent on
plaintext because I have brought the
server I could drop all the packets and
I could stay for the passwords and you
know and people didn't believe me that
that was done and I just showed one of
my one of my student friends like look
it's take your password he said damn
yeah so I said so I started going online
in 1995 so that was very early so it was
things like golfer and telnet and and
arcane library methods there was no
internet search yet at that time we had
a well on my house and we were I was
that annoying noise or a
like three stages across in a little al
person to move along and then yeah and
then every webpage would be like loading
got a bit of a picture yes yeah and that
seems to be my early memories I think
when I first started using u2 that we
didn't use the web that much the Atari
wasn't up to it particularly before I
got actual tcp/ip collectively we one of
the things we did was we emailed people
and I can remember that I was a big fan
of Babylon 5 still AM and at that time
the writer J michael Straczynski had his
email address public and I can remember
emailing him with questions about things
in the show and he would respond so that
was great you sort of emailing the
people who are creating things
well my first memories of going online I
was in a student house in the early 90s
and a friend of mine bought a 14400
modem and he had somehow come up well
discovered some phone numbers for BBS's
bulletin board systems I think it was
bullied by bulletin board system anyway
BBS is where you could go onto a
bulletin board and leave posts or read
things or download things from them and
this BBS would allow them you to have a
certain amount of internet time through
their system so that was my first memory
of going online we sent a few emails we
looked at a few things and I supposedly
went from that unfortunately I'm no
nearly 52 and my memory is too much
depleted and deteriorated compared to
what it used to be I can't really
remember it's ridiculous I can't
remember sending a first email I
certainly I was at university between
1985 1990 do four undergraduate degree
and I certainly remember mucking around
with the man for him smoking around with
the faxes and playing around but I can't
remember nanny mail what I can vividly
remember however is going to a
synchrotron which is a particle
accelerator a wheat condensed matter
physicists aren't so much interested in
the particles were interested in the
light those particles give off and that
was in a place called eros tree which is
pretty well equidistant between
Liverpool and Manchester right in the
middle in Liverpool Manchester and I
remember going there to do an experiment
and sending an excited email box and you
won't
believe it they've got a browser here
and you can actually see images on it it
downloads images and put it without any
sort of FTP stuff and that's my
operating man we're getting so excited
of a brave so it was Netscape or not
strip as they used to call it that
brought up the images and I remember
sort of that type of thing
that's my overriding memory and of
course dial-up but everybody says
dial-up I'm sure I had an Amiga computer
right this is like an Amiga 500 or 1200
I can remember and I remember spending
hours downloading the debian 2.0
distribution from the internet this is
probably you know it's probably 60
megabytes or something like that ours
now is downloading it so I can install
it cuz I've heard about this Linux thing
I was interested in it and so I saw I
was downloading these packages and
packages and like gradually sort of
installing it on my on my Amiga and
that's sort of one of the earliest
things I remember
I also remember again going on to
download demos so you know people would
write these kind of demos for the Amiga
pushing the hardware to the limit and
you know this is like two or three
megabytes and you know it's like hours
or downloading just to kind of watch
this demo because you used to have to
get that stuff from public domain discs
so you'd send some money through the
post and say I want these discs and
you'd get these discs back in the post
and so be able to do that via the
internet was a kind of completely
different experience but you know
obviously it took a really really long
time I remember emailing a friend who's
in Australia on a gap here and they were
on a university system over there
assuming that we'd be doing backwards
and forward emails so they this email
popped up and they sent a reply and
thought we'd be back on it but we didn't
go along online again from the police so
yeah it will it was definitely in its
infancy that sort of system for us as
consumers at home even though the
internet was obviously whenever it
already was 20 years old or whatever it
was already I also remember actually
with it going back to the Amiga again
spending hours trying to configure
something called a me TCP
which is like a TCP stack for the Amiga
and it was really you know I had no
experience of using these sorts of bits
software like you know networking
software so spending how I was trying to
configure it just to get online and I
completely failed and I think we ended
up buying some kind of some other TCP
stack software first time I saw the
Internet was when I was at work and they
brought in this computer and plugged a
modem in and when
this is a great new thing the internet
we went to the search thing and it
brought back hardly any results because
there was nothing on there so we kind of
went come back to us when there's
actually things on there a couple years
after that I got an email address and
started it was actually a good
communication tool and things started
appearing on the web and it started
actually being practical then so but
until then we'd use Janet University but
it wasn't didn't really have internet
connectivity all you could do was talk
to students and academics from my first
memory of the internet is disability to
see it takes images from you know other
places on earth I wasn't there but I
could read what other people were saying
I'm thinking that was fantastic first
electronic communication through the
chat programs at the time if I recall
correctly there was something called I
see shot Venus I don't get it I can but
yeah so I do remember the chat teen
programs that will allow you to you know
talk to people that you haven't met
before and I was strange but very
interesting feeling really the first
things I can remember which can't be the
first things but it's like using IRC
using things like the under net and
using FTP servers this type of thing and
I remember that we did and very early on
we did an OECD project that looked at
the use of digital technology and the
internet for education so we started
communicating and chatting via IRC chat
rooms etc we were in the math building
which is what oh I aren't
and we didn't actually have a connection
to the outside world but psychology did
say you could connect across to
psychologists computer dial-up London
log into one of London's nodes and then
you could use the Internet
I'm very very slow and of course it was
going across satellite so you connect to
I don't know we weren't very many sites
but there were a few places you could
pick up software so you log into those
because it was getting over a satellite
you type like letter A and it would take
about three seconds for the a to come
back and so you'd start typing and then
you get very confused halfway through
and have to delete it all and this
painfully slow but we thought it was
wonderful at the time first time I used
it for my own benefit was trying to
contact Alan Guth in it was at MIT he
still is
one of the most famous cosmologists
alive that came up with the idea of
inflation and I wanted to visit the u.s.
I was there I was at Imperial and we
used to have to go up a corridor there
was the only computers where there were
three three computers up at the end of
the corridor and we'd have to go to this
really dark room and the computers were
green little symbols going across them
that was the font style and you type in
your message and very and then send it
and you'd hear it got ping and each of
the destinations it was it was as if it
was being carried each line was pinging
pinging pinging and then eventually it
pinged Alan Guth MIT and it said message
received and I thought oh wow who's the
first time and then you have to wait
about a day or two days and then I'd
kept going back and gotten the thing and
then one day he said yeah come along
come on go so I went over to her with
the US I saw Alan goons Asajj camera
shaker you win the Nobel Prize
yeah so I raised at or I went to Chicago
I went to MIT I went to Berkeley
and it was great the internet the
Internet rules our lives and he had
contacts with UCL and so we got into
this sort of Internet and ARPANET and
early connections to that and I started
working on email software to try and
make sense of all this stuff that was
going on get rid of all these
exclamation marks